une vague cidre hive éphémère à
rambouillet la première opération de
vaccination en drive dans les yvelines
ici les personnes peuvent recevoir une
première dose du vaccin files heures
presque sans descendre de leur voiture
un système qui permet d'être plus rapide
sur place l'équipe est en capacité de
vacciner 1200 personnes par jour c'est
vraiment pour fluidifier permettent un
maximum de vaccination en un minimum de
temps et finalement potentialiser le
temps des personnes venant se faire
vacciner parce que ça évite tout
simplement le moment de trouver un
stationnement pour pouvoir aller dans un
centre de vaccination
concrètement un sens de circulation a
été mis en place
première étape un questionnaire à
remplir avant d'arriver à la zone de
vaccination la deuxième étape est donc
la vaccination par un professionnel de
santé ou un pompier après avoir revu le
questionnaire avec la personne est bien
être certain qu'il n'ya aucune
problématique s'il n'y a pas de
problématique le plat personnes est
vaccinée et termine sur la troisième
zone qui est la zone administrative un
certificat de vaccination est ensuite
fourni avec un rendez-vous de deuxième
dose il peut être effectué sur ce même
centre ou ailleurs depuis le début de la
semaine entre 1500 et 2000 premières
doses ont déjà été injectés
c'est pratique c'est rapide en plus là
pas de problème de stationnement
donc voila c'était l'occasion en fait ça
a été très rapide et ça je pense que
quand les gens travaillent c'est une
bonne chose de pouvoir se faire vacciner
assez rapidement et et puis bal en plus
rester à proximité notre voiture s'est
quand même
en plus on n'attend pas pendant des
heures donc donc en tout cas c'est pau
c'est positif
là je suis encore en habit de travail
parce que je viens de sortir j'ai du
boulot et j'ai fait ça en cinq minutes
donc c'est ça a été rapide la vaccine
drive de rambouillet est encore
accessible jusqu'à demain vendredi 11
juin 20h30 avec ou sans rendez vous dans
six semaines de l'opération sera
réitérée pour les deuxièmes 12